tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigenti oggi siamo su wales
oppure se lander man mano è più mi sono
giocato poche volte scusate non lo
riconosco vabbè partiamo prima che
diventi più stupido di quanto non lo sia
già
benché black box sforzo va bene così non
basketball madonna chissà ragazzi mi
chiama michael jordan 2.0 tanta frutta
roba degli altri se non so come ho fatto
ma non importa io può fa questo e
football dicono ancora ragazzo che non
lo sa nessuno il calcio lo sa nessuno ve
lo giuro che non sa nessuno bastardo mi
stava parando pour ce l'ho fatta per
miracolo ma va bene qualcosa mi dice che
non doveva andare così veloci fa ci
penso io a entrare in buca posso cagare
dentro sì ecco perfetto è la madonna
quante palle chiocciola via fermi la ma
dov'è la buca eccola gli perfetto allora
devi fare di ricentrare il buco zio
c'entra il buon quella dove si fermano
le pareti bastarde forza perfetto non so
non fate domande va bene così
l'importante è sempre centrare il buco
solo centrale il buco ok
ecco l'ho preso e morto di chi sa che
mira scusami steve che non vuole va beh
sì sfigato che la merda con reis
richiama fantastico perché ragazzi io
guido così col culo e si usa ragazzi
guidare col culo è una roba che migliori
piloti lo sanno fare la cosa molto più
ho vinto da riuscita a vincere miss oh
spappolato in 20mila pezzi ma ok poco
fight mlc è la madonna e melges c'è di
strano
snoop dogg dove se noi dove gli snob dog
eccolo ciao ho ucciso sono blog regala
roba spandau surface fantastico
chi era quello mlg geiger freddi è la
madonna sacche fredde non ho mai visto
freddi con con gli occhiali così e le
canne geniale stanic certo ma che il
break
certo vi prego basta che un re che ho
già rovinato la mia infanzia l'ultima
volta quindi lasciamo perdere 99 per
cento dai facciamo anche se impossible
che lo vedo bello bella merda invece che
casino che bordello
e vince così a caldo lancia cloud blog
sud
ok da dove lanciarli per difendermi
fantastico sono morto che ha visto
giocare sto gioco
tu non puoi passare bastardo ci ho
provato ragazzi ma ci riproviamo nino è
come effetto questo è morto su la donna
che testata muori maledetto machete dai
divi che le fasi
minchia che ciò che è 18 fattoria questo
bene shock cioè ragazzi è stata la cosa
più bella che abbia mai fatto
complimenti per il livello perché
salvime seven se facciamo anche questo
mi manca ancora questo devo sopravvivere
siete secondi ma perchè pensate che non
ci riesca
no le spade dai sono vivo niente niente
non presa non presa compreso sono ancora
vivo però sono ancora io sono ancora
vivo dai è resisti resisti
sì dai
oddio cosa ho fatto basta se non so come
ho fatto non mi chiede va bene così
dolci per fare vabbè allora nell'estate
proprio tirando lega ce l'ha ce l'ho nel
sangue non c'è niente da fare
vai in mente freddy's 4 bedroom e la e
fai da tè freddi su happy night di è la
madonna insomma è arrivato cosi lontano
può interesse cioè c'è l'armadio
ma chi è figo c'è anche lei sono anche
le 13 9 fantastico oddio che cazzo è
ciao caro che mi venga e butta tutto a
posto sono le tre di notte ragazzi ma
ciao ti va di assaggiare il mio q
lettino zio mi fa più paura di file ed è
freddy's veramente regia fantastico a
eva è la madonna ci sono tutti ragazzi
sono le 4 di notte di questo che sono
andato perfetto cosa facciamo tre
pupazzi un [ __ ] sono le cinque è la
madonna era madonna che york
la [ __ ] sono pagati ma cos'era ragazzi
6 del mattino fantastico va bene tanta
roba regata clown facciamo clown che
rispetta gli altri mi sembra meno tetro
esatto si può giocare tranquillamente
senza che delle persone brutte bilancino
dei coltelli mi spuntino dal terreno
bilancino delle mele mi stuprino la mano
quella tra stupri snow nella madonna che
belle scarpe
io ho una mela lo sai che i favi j
mangiano solo mele come gli sci nigam
pivot buttarmi giù perfetto un'altra
importante ragazzi e averlo più grosso è
il frutto il conto giorno devo andar via
vado via sì nello shan ti lascio un
piede nel caso ti serva a deve entrarci
in gola perfetto sei morto che bello
cos'era
questa è questo e quello del mcdonald
del ronald mcdonald
tutto sembra anche abbastanza carino lo
scoop alzerei come fosse un bambino il
problema è che chi devi togliere i
[ __ ]
cosa fai bang bang cosa ma [ __ ] lo
re di clown
l'edizione no dai clown king tu sei il
re dei clown
io ho una mela zio ok adduce lai più
grosse l'importante zia non è avere il
frutto più grosso ma saperlo usare
ricorda pigra un po a demo cos'è la
madonna mi già mega mega nono ciak
ragazzi control che facciano space to
start
sto cercando il culo yeah yeah yeah che
cazzo ma sii serio ma che figo 9 è un
mega ragazzi mega mediano annuncia che
mi mancava ci ha visto godzilla
ma è veramente più figo questo cioè non
ho parole che qua che shaq e roma che
movimento di gamma sexy ragazza fosse
sempre così non lo sa che lo sceglierei
ogni tre secondi e bella poi appuntita
sembra quella di di chuck norris che
sotto la bamba la bamba la barba un
altro pugno alla mamma five dei tè
freddi sfogo fight cazzo è ovvio dio ma
veramente sono contro gli animatronics
l'est it all old chica old freddi perché
siete così magri lega ha posto partita
scusa
come faceva col braccio stava facendo
una minchia
gazzi 8 a posto all de boni bravo frate
questo qua e la volpe old fox he ciao
zio te che tutti che muoiono in modo da
idioti proprio bonus gol di freddi caso
non ho mai trovato io quando il freddo
si sono ricompattate morto a [ __ ] fa
chi è a sono morto anche solo comunque
un figo in si livelli no vabbè ma non so
perché sta prendendo così piede fai un
été freddy's tanto da essere messo
addirittura in pvc non vorrei dire
ragazzi melina interbrand yen ai melina
che sarà per me li na design gengis rai
nel level ford ciao mia questa melina
cia melina melina e obesa melina è
partita perché hamelin è morto dio
questo mi sembra troppo mister game
watch quello di super smash bros
via via via via via via via via via
bravissimo la donna che salto ciao nonno
a posto cosa non ho letto per ha vinto
senza aver letto vinto sto facendo
ragazzi un quiz in tedesco non vorrei
dire ragazzi quasi ben franks wenders
larkin druges la mia ovviamente la
risposta è mia ed è giusta ragazzi sono
riusciti a far di meno in dei miei quiz
non vorrei dire questo in tedesco sta
seccando tutta pizza ebbe questa l'ho
capita keynes dons bn snap stickers
melina ma secondo me è kebab ragazzi
sono pronti ad altre domande cos'è lang
strum
va bene andiamo nel lang strano ragazzi
lang fra me e sempre a risposta e ve lo
dico bravo col culetto a posto sono
arrivato nel lang strahm che gol ma va
bene che ma che livello figure o allora
mi sono tolto il berretto in segno di
festeggiamenti fantastico che poi non è
un berretto e un casco ma per me va su
tutti i berretti
ho vinto cazzo nola l'ultima monetta
volevo una bella e tre su quattro
va bene così ho azzeccato tutto in
tedesco cioè non vorrei dire ragazzi
però la propaggine si fa sentire finiti
ragazzi facciamo un paio di miei livelli
prima di concludere perché se non sono
contento vj impossible
questo mi sembra giusto concesso certo
grazie ragazzi di mettermi cessi nei
livelli siete molto gentile
sono bravo a questo gioco mi sto
semplicemente stupendo di me stesso dyka
bravo zio bravo bravo fatto anche il
video bravo ma se tifo andassi a sì ma
che cristo concesso mi sono ucciso e ci
siamo ci siamo ci siamo ci siamo ho
pagato un poco ragazzi io quasi quasi me
ne sto disteso qua a prendere il sole
perché sono un figo ma dai già fi
buttarti almeno giu almeno giu di un
nervoso giu tu devi andare giù bra
dall'altra parte [ __ ] ci siamo
ragazzi non ci credo come mi ha preso se
no va bene una parola ragazzi ma
veramente cioè ci sto mettendo anni solo
per fare questo livello lega non ci
posso credere mai
ma perché ma perché ho vinto bene bene
va bene ok ma poi fa vj livello strano
ricordi quando l'hai ucciso a zio la
vostra foto ha forse non si può mettere
l'apostrofo sorapis scusati a nuvole non
me lo ricordo però un arpione ce l'ha a
sì che si può mettere con te perché hai
una touran loschi vi sempre quasi sempre
un altro al pianeti vuole operare al
cervello perché gli va
[Musica]
ecco qua droga ecco questa cosa qua
questa cosa qua è quella che prendi tu
zio qui esattamente quello che prendi
quattro ragazzi con quello che episodio
anche se ero l'ultimo livello mi ha
lasciato allibito va beh spero che vi
sia piaciuto un mi piace se pensate che
quel ragazzo si faccia di droghe perché
penso sia così ma nonostante questo
ragazzi siamo sempre tutti una grande
famiglia di f quindi lasciamo perdere e
poi io ho rotto la tastiera quindi tanto
vale quindi ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato momento
mi piace anche la pace vari facebook e
con i video tatana descrizione suicidi
stretta e ci vediamo il prossimo video
belle ragazze